the most action-packed episode of rings
of power is out and was giving me
flashbacks of Dante's Peak
I felt that in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the episode new
Clues on who Sauron is the creation of
Mordor and connections to Lord of the
Rings I'll also be saving spoilers for
the next few episodes near the end of
the video but I'll warn you before we
get to that now let's get into it adar's
hand plants alpharin seeds in the ground
these are the same types of seeds
Bronwyn gave arandir in episode 1 and in
rings lore these flowers are said to
have sprouted around Ellendale's tomb
elves are said to plant these before
battle for it's said that the Valar or
those powers that shape the world watch
over those who tend to them so it seems
a dollar still holds on to some of his
Elvish customs and what army couldn't
use a nice pep talk and we can also see
waldrig in among the crowd the last we
saw of him he was tasked with killing
Rowan to prove his allegiance to Sauron
this is likely why Adar tasks him with
one of the most important tasks using
the sword key to destroy the dam that
will eventually cast the Southlands Into
Darkness making their way to the Elven
Outpost of osterith the Orcs have fallen
into a trap last episode braunwen
inadvertently gave arendir the idea to
have the tower literally fall on them
thankfully the place has been abandoned
and while the Orcs searched the
fortification Adar lays his eyes on the
sculpted wall this will later find to be
the lock Theo's sword will open a door
can smell the elf but before he can be
caught aundir Springs the Trap and
collapses the tower killing many Orcs in
the process this is great news for the
humans however their celebration is
short-lived adarna's men will come for
revenge and they must fortify the small
town of tierharad across the sundering
Seas izodor is living that glorious
stable boy life we've seen how he's
yearned to travel to Middle Earth and
now he has his chance on Queen Muriel's
expedition to the Southlands there he
meets Galadriel for the first time she
can see the shore with her Keen l golden
eyes but soon it will be visible to
isildor he's ashamed to be a stable
sweep and tells Galadriel that he wants
to get as far away from numenor as
possible stating that it's not the real
numenor I interpreted this as meaning
that numenor has strewn away from the
greatness it once was and no longer
stands by the ideals by which it was
founded it's too easily perverted by
ambitious men like our farazon who seek
to exploit this city for their own
personal gain rather than Elevate the
city as a whole the numenoreans head
toward the Bay of belfalas up the river
anduin and East toward the Southlands
you may remember the River anduin from
The Fellowship of the Ring where the
fellowship passed The Argonaut those two
giant pillars of isildor and his brother
anorian who we haven't met yet of course
at this time these monuments have been
created and actually appear further up
the river at nen hethrowel we also learn
a little bit about what happened to
isildur's mother she drowned According
to ellendil which is somewhat ironic
since she comes from a family of sailors
back in Tierra and around here attempts
to break the sword by Smashing it not
sure how he thought this would work but
I guess it was worth a try so if it
can't be destroyed he will hide it
somewhere it can never be found however
little does he know that Theo is keeping
a close eye on him this is how he knows
where it is later on in the episode
erandir who in episode 1 was despised by
the southlanders has now become a pseudo
leader for this ragtag group of refugees
he's devised a plan to trap the Orcs
using flaming wagons having their
archers pick off as many of the Orcs as
possible but before the battle begins
erandir plants these Alfred seeds
telling Bronwyn that after this is over
they will plant the rest in a New Garden
where they'll live together with Theo
it's here that they have their first
kiss of the show the defense of tutorad
starts off rather successful many Orcs
are caught in the fire and mowed down
with arrows while erandir fails this
giant orc with the help of Bronwyn but
just when it looks like the villagers
have vented off the orc invasion they
come to a startling realization many of
the attackers aren't Orcs at all but
their fellow Southland who swore
themselves to Adar this was but a
preliminary attack preceding the full
force of adar's orc Army in the second
attack both Bronwyn and our poor
Treadwell are shot with arrows as the
defending villagers barricade themselves
within the tavern here Theo must
cauterize his mother's wound as she
comes close to death but Adar is on the
move and at first I was like how come he
doesn't burn the entire building down
with everyone inside and then I realized
he needs that sword only by
interrogating those inside can he find
out where it is with bronwyn's head
literally on The Chopping Block Theo
gives in and retrieves the blade from a
tile beneath the tavern floor I guess
Aaron deer really needs to work on his
hiding spots and while it looks like All
Is Lost for our southlanders Adar hears
the sound of galloping horses the
numenoreans have arrived more than
evening the playing field it's important
to note at this moment Adar tells
waldrig he has an important task for him
this is where the handoff of the sword
is done and will later find Adar has
tricked Galadriel and given her a fake
the battle is filled with ton of little
moments like galadriel's sick moves I
guess you pick up a thing or two when
you're thousands of years old valondial
saves antimo and the queen allows
isildur to gain some much needed
fighting experience there's also this
moment where izodor comes to his
father's Aid after being saved by Hal
brand a definite nod to him doing the
same thing at the war of the last
Alliance which leads to him cutting off
the finger-holding sauron's One Ring of
Power Adar runs off with this decoy
weapon with Galadriel and halbrand
chasing after him this is most likely a
diversion so that waldrick can use the
real sword to destroy the damn
eventually they're able to stop this
dark elf and halbron asks if he
remembers him there's some history
between these two but Adar does not
recall who he is did he kill someone in
his family we just don't know however
this episode more than any prior has led
me to believe that Hal brand could be
Sauron I've seen a few other videos
claiming this and dismiss them for lack
of evidence thinking halbrand would be
more of a Naz ghoul however there were a
ton of suspicious things in this this
episode that had me questioning
everything let's take a look at the
evidence at the end of the episode
halren becomes the de facto King of the
southlanders an area which will become
Mordor what better position to be in if
you're Sauron plus no one has ever seen
this guy before and the only link to any
sort of noble line is this emblem he
carries around everyone just kind of
buys into him being King which I thought
was very convenient in the book Sauron
is said to be a master manipulator and
sorcerer who knows what this Hal burned
character is doing to sway people to his
will when halbrand confronts Adar he
asks the dark elf if he knows who he is
we're led to believe Adar may have
killed halbrand's family but there's no
evidence of that what if halbrand wants
to kill Adar for a different reason as
revenge for killing Sauron later on in
the episode Adar tells Galadriel that he
killed the dark lord maybe this is why
Hal brand asked if he knew him not
because of his family but because he is
in fact the dark lord resurrected in the
book Sauron at this time was known to to
take a quote Fair Visage so him looking
like you or I and not some disfigured
dark elf makes more sense but the
biggest clue that leads me to believe he
is Sauron is this brief scene between
Galadriel and Hal brand where there is
the slightest inkling the two could be
falling in love he talks about how
fighting alongside her has quote given
him this feeling and even talks about
wishing he could bind it to his being
bind is also an interesting word since
it's part of the famous quote regarding
the one ring and in the darkness behind
them and gladriel feels this feeling too
both of them share a look and as they're
interrupted Galadriel lets out this kind
of quivering sigh am I crazy here guys
or is this the start of help andreal gal
brand we can work on the name but what
better person for Galadriel to fall in
love with than the person she has sworn
to kill from a narrative and
storytelling perspective Hal Rand just
makes sense back in town the Battle Is
Over valendil has managed to get spots
for isildur and antimo on a special
Mission led by Galadriel to track down
the remaining Orcs antimo decides to
stay back instead wondering how close he
came to death during the battle so it'll
be interesting if this is the last we
see him galatriel interrogates Adar in
the same Barn where Theo first found the
sword she calls him a moriondor son of
the dark a twisted elf by morgoth but he
prefers to be referred to as Uric which
is black speech for orc after morgoth's
defeat Sauron devoted himself to Healing
Middle Earth and sought to craft a power
that could harness the unseeing world
the unseeing world or The Wraith world
is that place Frodo goes while wearing
the ring something was missing for
Sauron to harness this power thus he
traveled to that Fortress we saw in
episode 1 which may be morgoth's first
Fortress of autumno their Adar
sacrificed his children the Orcs as part
of sauron's quest for this dark
knowledge and needed to harness the
power of the Unseen World Adar did not
like this and if we're to believe him he
killed Sauron there he set out to give
his children a home in the Southlands
the only problem is that his children
can't roam about during the day so he
devised an ingenious plan to detonate
the volcano casting the land in a dark
Haze of Ash you may remember last
episode he stared up at the sun
lamenting that he'll miss it this
mountain is what will be known as
Mountain doom and by unleashing the
Dam's water through an intricate series
of tunnels the cool water will mix with
the volcano's lava causing a gigantic
eruption but before this happens
Galadriel pulls her blade on Adar vowing
to eradicate every last orc leaving him
the last to die he recognizes that she
is no better than he filled with
bloodlust and revenge she too is an Uric
this time it's Hal brand who stops
Galadriel from killing Adar as she
unknowingly leaves with the decoy sword
one last time a Dar asks Hal brand who
he is but he doesn't answer if I had
lost my family to this guy you better
believe I'd be screaming what he did to
them so he remembers Galadriel gives the
decoy blade to out on deer wiping orc
blood off her brother's dagger he'll end
up giving the blade to Theo who said the
blade made him feel powerful but erandir
gives Theo the chance to redeem himself
for giving it up to a Dar by asking him
to give it over to the numenoreans to
drop into the ocean Aaron dear could
have done this himself but gives it to
Theo for this purpose Bronwyn is hailed
as a hero by Queen Muriel and in front
of the entire crowd halbrand is deemed
the true king of the Southlands
meanwhile Ellendale teaches his son
about this special bond between Horse
and Rider it was a lesson taught to him
by isildur's mother and he wishes to
learn more it's kind of the first time
these two have really bonded considering
isildor has been this defiant Sun since
we first saw him in episode 3. the
destruction of the dam causes the water
to flow through the tunnels creating
giant water spouts along tiharad the
volcanic eruption itself is massive
sending out a giant Shockwave and flying
rocks of flame in the commotion we see
that Adar has escaped his chains was he
let loose or did he manage to make his
own way out if it's the former the last
person we saw him with was Hal brand
it's hard to believe anyone will survive
this massive blast but if you you watch
my spoiler section we can see a bit of
what happens so without further Ado
here's your warning let's get into it
with episode 6 being numenorian and
Aaron dear center it's likely we'll pick
up back with the hard foots they're on
their way to the Grove where Nori said
there are countless apples and other
fruits to pick but judging by the
background here the place has started to
rot on the tree here you can see more of
these rotten apples I'm curious if these
guys now officially named the mystics
will catch up to them here we have an
eye-opening covered in Ash this appears
to be Galadriel Awakening from the
aftermath of the eruption so we can
confirm that she survives but damn it
does not look like a lot of people made
it out of there alive here's a character
by the name of the dweller one of the
three Mystics she's using some sort of
magic blowing this black smoke it could
be an editing fake out but the next shot
is of a leaf very similar to that found
in Linden traversing this cave last
episode we learned of the origin of
mithril an ancient legend where
lightning hit a tree and its roots
created this ore I wonder if this is any
way connected it to that there's also
this shot of a balrog which is different
than the shots found in episode 5 so
either we're going to see more of this
creature or that was simply promotional
material to get people more excited
about the show with only two episodes
left that's it for the yet to be seen
footage I hope you enjoyed this video
please consider liking and subscribing
and leave a comment about what you think
of the show thanks for watching and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember I felt that
thank you
foreign